en el último de los vídeos empecé en mi
fábrica de cupcakes y era el tipo más
rico en el pueblo y bueno estaba me
estaba yendo también a trabajo
competencia después imran hizo su propia
fábrica de cupcakes se llevó todo mi
negocio cobrando 290 x cupcake y bueno
creo que el número que usé en el último
vídeo era que vendía 500 mil cupcakes
después tuvo una gran rentabilidad creo
que era del 20 por ciento se llevó todo
mi negocio y bueno dije bueno estoy
solamente cobrando 3 dólares por cupcake
y estaba vendiendo 250.000 de ellos y mi
rentabilidad se iba casi a cero no han
aparecido al punto de equilibrio después
al final dije bueno déjenme elevar
tantito el precio porque bueno tengo
cierto número de clientes que les gusta
como pero la caja registradora o viven
cerca de mi fábrica oa lo mejor creen
que estoy guapo y nada más por eso lo
compran como sea así que incrementó un
poco el precio digamos y bueno tengo
cierta ligera ganancia pero si pierdo a
algunas personas que querían comprar mis
cupcakes verdad pero bueno
tengo cierta ganancia esta es una forma
más o menos de maximizar a lo largo del
tiempo y poco a poco la gente se va
dando cuenta de kim gran cobra mucho
menos por los cupcakes y se van a su
negocio así que empiezo a perder cada
vez más clientes verdad y esto por
supuesto no es una situación sustentable
vino aquí en rne y empezó a vender 500
mil verdad
así era como lo tenía correcto entonces
tiene una gran rentabilidad yo tengo muy
poca y sólo estoy haciendo cuarenta mil
dólares al año él está haciendo 300.000
y necesito traer de nuevo mi negocio así
que lo que tengo que hacer es bajar el
precio para ganarme algunos de los
clientes que se habían estado yendo con
in brand y ganar a algunos de los
clientes que surgen en el pueblo de
digamos este no son un juego de suma
cero un juego de suma cero es cuando lo
que yo gano alguien más lo pierde dentro
de la competencia y al revés verdad pero
bueno quizás haya gente que a lo mejor
empiece a cambiar su alimentación sana y
empiece a consumir cupcakes para sus
requerimientos diarios de azúcar eso no
sé así que digamos ahora que corto el
precio lo bajo y bajó el precio hasta
272 dólares con 70 centavos y ahora
estoy dispuesto o tengo la capacidad de
vender 400 mil cupcakes
muy bien y bueno tomé algo del negocio
de un gran verdad algunos clientes
digamos que tomé que se queda él con 400
mil ahora
los cupcakes digamos me ignora beso que
iba a decir ahorita en esta realidad que
plantee estoy obteniendo un 15 por
ciento de rentabilidad mientras que un
gran el 7 por ciento digamos que ahora
hay un tercer competidor vikram y dice
bueno yo puedo gastar toda mi vida
haciendo cupcakes incluso si tengo el 7
por ciento de rentabilidad digo un 15
por ciento sería ideal pero bueno entra
al mercado y digamos que es un un
negocio un un empresario pues pequeño
digamos que invierte 500 mil tiene una
capacidad de 400 mil cupcakes y como es
una fábrica pequeña es un poco menos
eficiente no entonces viene al mercado y
dice bueno yo disfruto mi vida no tanto
de hacerme rico o de más digo tiene que
pagar la renta o no yo que sé no pero el
enlace su felicidad de ver a la gente
comer cupcakes digamos entonces haciendo
eso trabaja a capacidad máxima no sé
cortando precios lo que sea
entonces digamos que opera a capacidad
máxima de 400.000 cupcakes y no se
empieza a robar negocio a todos verdad
así entonces cuál es ahora cómo queda la
situación ahora mi rentabilidad se va al
7%
imran se va casi al punto de equilibrio
no está haciendo dinero y vikram está
haciendo un 12 por ciento de
rentabilidad porque bueno esencialmente
despidió a mucha gente estaba tiene la
capacidad de vender todo lo que produce
y entonces la capacidad total
en esta segunda hoja de cálculo que de
hecho déjenme ponerlo de nuevo lo pueden
descargar en khan academy punto diagonal
downloads diagonal cupcakes punto x ls
pero bueno vikram entró al mercado y
ahora agregó es de capacidad total
verdad esto es el número total de
cupcakes que las fábricas en el mercado
pueden producir la demanda total son 1
punto 1 millón de cupcakes que se venden
al año y bueno en esta situación qué
quieres sucede
tengo esta capacidad de extra digamos
sólo el 32 por ciento de mi capacidad se
está utilizando y obvia
el mercado los precios del mercado para
los cupcakes sobre el costo marginal de
producir un cupcake es mucho mejor así
que brand está ahorita en el tope es el
hombre más rico y quizás el más rico
pero sí tiene porque tiene una gran
herencia de su abuela ya habíamos dicho
así que dices pues tonto soy el tipo más
rico en el pueblo soy el más eficiente y
tengo toda la capacidad así que voy a
bajar y además dice pues no tengo
rentabilidad así que voy a cobrar unos
70 por cupcake y voy a despedir gente
voy a hacer que este negocio salga
adelante entonces se empieza a llevar
todo un nuevo mercado verdad que ahora
quiere comer cupcakes que a lo mejor
antes comía twinkies porque a lo mejor
los pinches están cada uno en 180
entonces está
subiendo la demanda total verdad empieza
a vender entonces dos millones de
cupcakes al año digamos está al máximo
de su capacidad y tiene una gran una
gran rentabilidad verdad y mata todo
nuestro negocio se lleva todos los
clientes
y también el de vikram y el mío entonces
así que dice ok tenemos que igualar sus
precios no vamos a igualarlo vamos a ver
qué pasa si yo vendo en unos 70 y
también vi gran vende en unos 70
y dijimos que en unos 70 la gente está
bastante dispuesta a comer cupcakes
digamos que hay a 2 millones de personas
que compran los cupcakes entonces bueno
vikram sólo podía 400 mil cupcakes solo
podía vender esa cantidad verdad
esa era su capacidad total
y el resto lo dividimos entre los otros
dos así que nos toca de 800.000 a cada
uno
miami muy bien y como pueden ver hay
cierta tendencia general que si la gente
tiene capacidad extra esto es como un
incentivo para bajar los precios
relativamente a otras personas pero si
no estás usando toda tu capacidad
entonces hay cupcakes que no se están
produciendo pero que de alguna u otra
forma podrían estar siendo producidos y
el costo de producirlo digamos en este
caso es relativamente bajo así que
mientras yo lo venda en algo más caro
que lo que me cuesta estoy haciendo
dinero que de otra forma no lo podría
hacer pero cuando hacemos eso en
realidad estamos bajando los precios del
mercado y todos los elementos de la
competencia deben hacer eso por eso la
competencia es buena y los monopolios
son malos porque cuando yo era el único
que controlaba los cupcakes en el pueblo
yo podría mantener los precios altos
tenía incluso aunque mi utilización se
fuera para abajo verdad en esta
competencia real digamos hay gran
incentivos para que cuando tenemos esta
ciudad extra especialmente cuando hay
mucha capacidad extra tenemos gran
incentivos para bajar los precios así
que esta capacidad se pueda utilizar
verdad si estamos corriendo al máximo de
nuestra capacidad como vimos en unos
vídeos anteriores bueno que cuando por
ejemplo cuando era solo yo el que estaba
vendiendo y estaba al máximo de mi
capacidad estaba dispuesto a subir los
precios
pero bueno eso es una de las lecciones
de estos vídeos que cuando tenemos
grandes ganancias como en los cupcakes
cuando estaba yo solito compitiendo en
el mercado bueno tenemos grandes
ganancias y eso atrae competencia y la
competencia trae capacidad verdad porque
fuimos de un millón de de cupcakes que
podríamos vender a 3.4 millones y cuando
todo el mundo tiene capacidades extra
este incentivo es para bajar los precios
así que pueden tratar de cachar esta
utilidad extra que tienen verdad
entonces si queremos evitar eso
podríamos reunirnos nosotros tres y
decir a ver chicos no hay que hacernos
tontos vamos a agregar todos en un
precio y entonces hasta esto podría
parecer un buen movimiento de negocios
pero eso nos llevaría a la cárcel si no
tenemos buenos árbitros digamos porque
estaríamos formando un cartel un grupo
que quiere controlar los precios y eso
en una competencia
al no es bueno no es no es honesto
entonces nosotros solo deberíamos estar
compitiendo bajando nuestros precios
pero bueno el tema general aquí es que
cuando tenemos una gran utilización de
los recursos bueno estamos por eso
estamos en esta hoja de cálculo y
hablando de inflación en general pero
los precios suben cuando tenemos gran
utilización verdad eso si todos
estuviéramos al cien por ciento de hecho
vamos a hacer ese escenario a ver
digamos que por alguna razón todo el
mundo tiene rentas bajas que tenemos no
sé todos decidimos que nuestro dinero
extra viniendo de nuestras ganancias de
los cupcakes vamos a lograr hacer que la
demanda total se vaya hasta arriba y que
estemos vendiendo un millón de cupcakes
al año
imran vende dos millones de cupcakes al
año vivirán sus 400 mil que pueden así
que todos estamos al cien por ciento de
la capacidad de utilización y entonces
la rentabilidad es bastante buena
digamos todos como grupo decimos bueno
pues sí ya estamos vendiendo lo todo
pues vamos a subir los precios porque no
nos está afectando mucho a la demanda
así que digamos que la gente los desea
tanto los cupcakes que los podemos subir
a dos dólares y eso no nos mejora
muchísimo en nuestra ganancia verdad en
brand dice pues no soy tonto voy a
subirlo también a dos dólares y por
supuesto
mi gran también hará lo mismo verdad
entonces todo el mundo tiene una
rentabilidad mucho mejor y digamos que
puede argumentar que en este caso con
tres jugadores está esta es suficiente y
digamos que sigue sucediendo lo mismo
podemos seguir subiendo los precios y
bueno quizás ahora sí ya tenga un
pequeño impacto sobre la demanda verdad
todo el mundo lo subimos a tres dólares
y digamos que tiene un ligero cambio en
la en la demanda entonces digamos que yo
vendo 950.000 que invanden de 1.8
millones al año y vikram vende 380 mil
cupcakes al año pero en general si si
nos fijamos en esta situación
al subir nuestros precios aún obtenemos
buenos buenos ingresos verdad así que
mientras tengamos una alta utilización y
la gente todavía debate cuál es el nivel
de utilización de las industrias donde
tiene sentido elevar los precios pero
cuando tenemos esa situación no hay
obstáculo en principio que nos impida
seguir incrementando los precios por
otro lado cuando tenemos una baja
utilización
entonces podría no parecer completamente
bueno si es racional como competidor
pero cuando tenemos baja utilización
queremos bajar los precios para que
podamos usar más la fábrica pueden jugar
con esto pensar sobre otro tipo de
escenarios
esa es la gran idea que quería en la que
llegáramos que una gran utilización de
nuestra capacidad total hará que los
precios se incrementen la baja
utilización hará que bajen y de hecho
voy a decir dos últimas cosas una última
utilización te permitirá elevar los
precios
y cuando incremente los precios vas a
tener una mejor rentabilidad y por otro
lado cuando tienes una gran rentabilidad
también tendrás que invertir para
construir más capacidad entonces esos
son los dos efectos de la gran
utilización
tenemos precios que se incrementan
después viene más capacidad y más
inversión baja utilización tiene la
situación contraria verdad no hay
incentivos para que haya fábricas y
después cada todos los jugadores en el
mercado van a tender a bajar sus precios
porque solo quieren utilizar sus
fábricas de lo contrario sus fábricas no
se utilizan de cualquier forma creo que
ya dije la misma cosa en cinco formas
distintas o algo así
regresaré en el próximo vídeo con la
herramienta de dibujo para que podamos
discutir más sobre inflación y deflación